- I have to read this from
here, because it's one
of my favorite things
that you said in the book,
obviously 'cause I'm in the
midst of a divorce right now,
which it's tough.
And you wrote about having
to release what you thought
of family was after getting divorced.
And I'm going through that now.
So I mean, I guess two questions it's like
what is it about especially young girls
'cause I remember reading
the fairytale thing,
you know, we all think it's
going to happen one way.
- Yeah.
- And then reality sets in and it's hard.
Like working at a marriage is very hard.
And when you do experience divorce
'cause I know you have an,
I am currently, I can't
I think 'cause I'm in the middle of it.
I can't even imagine doing it again.
I can't imagine being married again.
And one of my favorite things
in your book was it took
five times for him to
and I don't mean that in a funny way.
I read that.
Not as in like you were
making him kind of chase you.
I read that as in like,
look, she knew, she knew
that it was a big decision,
especially a blended family.
I walked into that as
well with my marriage
and it's a hard thing to
do when you walk into that.
And I don't know, I love
that by the time you said yes
he knew you meant it.
- Right.
- Yeah.
And I mean, how did you rework this
because I know a lot of women
out there that are in men
that are divorced and maybe cannot imagine
setting themselves up
for that again, you know?
- You know, it took me a long time.
It took me at least a year
to get on my feet again.
I think it was, I had
I didn't know anybody
that had been divorced.
I felt like it was a failure on my part.
I kept thinking.
- Yeah.
- You know, I lost my self esteem
because I kept thinking
what's wrong with me.
Why couldn't I make this work, and.
- There's so much shame
and guilt involved.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- And then just unexpectedly.
You know, I met Joe and it
was I had met him once before
but it was kind of a blind
date when he called me.
And then, but, you know,
I want to tell you Kelly,
I mean this is what I would say
to you if I were your mother.
- Yeah.
- You know, my mother always said to me,
things are gonna look better tomorrow.
And if you can take one day at a time,
and things will get better.
And, you know, I look back on
it now and I think, you know,
if I hadn't gotten divorced,
I never would have met Joe.
I wouldn't have the
beautiful family I have now.
- Yeah.
- So I really think things
happen for the best.
And I think Kelly, over
time, I don't know how long
it's been for you, but I
think over time you heal
and you're gonna be surprised
and I can't wait until
that day comes for you.
And you're going to call me
up and you're going to say,
"Hey Jill, you were right."
- Yeah, I was just kidding.
Yeah.
Well, it's just an amazing thing.
I love reading that though
'cause it was like most,
I think most women feel
pressure to say yes.
And then you feel like you're like
you don't love them if
you say no, I don't know.
I just found that an amazing
thing that you took your time
and we're like, let's make sure
especially 'cause kids were involved.
- Yeah.
- And especially from the
situation that they were involved.
- I love those boys so much.
- Yeah.
- And I tell Joe, that was
the reason I married him
because I fell in love with the boys.
- Yeah, that's so awesome.
But I want to talk about
this too, because I know
that you said cancer research
is really important to you.
We talked about that a minute ago,
but and you've talked
about it quite a bit.
And it's obviously a very
personal thing for you.
It's a personal thing for all of us.
Like you said, all
of us are touched by
cancer, unfortunately.
But I found it interesting
that you were very honest
about losing faith
because I've lost people.
And I know other people lost people
and especially if I go into
like a children's hospital or
and you see these young
little kids and you're like
I don't understand this.
Like I can't wrap my head
around why this is happening.
And it's hard for people
to not lose faith.
- Yes.
- Like, you know, people generally do.
So how do you still have
a very strong faith?
Have you worked, you know,
through that or do you,
did you have friends at home to do that?
- Well, I don't know
whether your audience knows
but we lost our son Beau to
cancer he was 46 years old.
And I prayed so hard every single day
that he was going to live.
And I felt like he was such
a special person that he
God would let him live and I just prayed
and prayed and then it
just wasn't meant to be in.
And when we lost Beau, it was hard
for me to keep my faith because
I had believed so strongly
in prayer and that he was,
you know, he'd make it.
And it took me a long time Kelly
and we were in a church
just like a year ago
and he's, Beau's been gone,
gosh, almost six years.
And a woman came up to me
in the church and she said,
"Jill I want to be your prayer partner."
And I said, prayer partner.
I had never even heard
of a prayer partner.
- I'm from the South I have.
- So yeah.
- Yeah.
- And it was in the South
and so she started to call me
and we would pray together.
And to this day, I mean she
calls me maybe twice a week
we email, we text one another
and it really helped
me find my faith again.
It was like, God was saying to me,
"Okay, Jill you've had time come back."
And so I felt that that was
a gift that she gave to me.
- Yeah, and what a beautiful
way to actually be able
to find your way back.
I know a lot of people
still struggle with that.